ولكن عندما تصاب بإصابة دماغية ناقصة الأكسجين ،
فهذا أمر خطير بالتأكيد لأن نقص الأكسجين
يعني بدون أكسجين وعندما
تذهب خلايا الدماغ بدون أكسجين يمكن أن
تبدأ بالتلف في وقت مبكر مثل ثلاث دقائق
، ثم عندما تكون بدون أكسجين لمدة
أربع إلى ست دقائق ، تبدأ فعليًا
للحصول على موت خلايا دماغية وفي
حالتها تم إعلان موتها دماغياً وهو
ما يختلف في الواقع عن كونها في
غيبوبة ورأيت هذا النوع المحدد
من الإصابات وأين سترى
بالطبع إصابة شديدة في الرأس ربما  السقوط
وهو أمر شائع ،
فهو في الواقع شائع لسوء الحظ ،
ونعم يمكنك رؤيته مع إصابات الدماغ
الرضحية ، يمكنك أيضًا رؤية إصابة الدماغ بنقص الأكسجين
مع نوبة ربو شديدة أو
جرعة زائدة من المخدرات مع توقف القلب
مع توقف التنفس مع السكتة الدماغية ، لذلك
هناك العديد من الطرق  للإصابة بنقص الأكسجين في
الدماغ وهناك طرق للوقاية منها
اعتمادًا على السبب في حالتها في
حوادث السيارات ووفقًا
لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض لدينا أكثر من 32000 حالة وفاة في
الولايات المتحدة كل عام من
حوادث السيارات يصاب أكثر من 2 مليون
شخص ويطلق عليها
حادث لسبب صحيح في كثير من الأحيان لا يمكنك
منعه ولكن هناك العديد من الأشياء التي
يمكننا القيام بها سوزان لمنع الحوادث التي
ترتدي أحزمة الأمان التي تمتلكها الولايات المتحدة
بالفعل  انخفاض معدل ارتداء
أحزمة المقاعد مقارنة بالدول الأخرى ذات الدخل المرتفع ،
كما أن واحدًا من كل ثلاث
حوادث للسيارات مرتبط
بالقيادة تحت تأثير الكحول ، يرتبط واحد من كل ثلاثة
تقريبًا بالسرعة ، ولذا يمكننا اتخاذ
تدابير وقائية لأن الإصابات الدرامية في
الدماغ يمكن أن تؤدي بالتأكيد إلى
إصابات دماغية زائدة.
نعم ، هناك شيء مهم حقًا ،
ففي حالتها كانت متبرعة
بالأعضاء ، كانت متبرعة بالأعضاء ، لذا من
المهم حتى عندما تكون صغيرًا
وبصحة جيدة إجراء هذه المناقشات ، لذا
خلال حياتها وموتها المأساوي ،
يمكنها إنقاذ ما يصل إلى 55 شخصًا  لأنها
متبرعة بالأعضاء